hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in chapter 5 of
book four of his discourses Epictetus is
going to talk about people who are
contentious and thereby become what
we're going to translate as brutal so
let's talk about these terms very
quickly the contentious is the Maquis
muy those people who always want to
scrap with other people who are you know
itching for a fight as we say they're
also you know going to be people who are
in certain ways self-contradictory this
this maki boy is coming from the same
term that we've been translating as
conflict or contradiction when we talk
about our ideas or our way of life now
the brutal another way of translating
that would be beast you but we might
translate that even better as animal
like when a person is behaving like an
animal they in our theory out there you
know they're you know this there is is a
beast an animal a wild thing right and
the question that we want to ask them is
how do these people end up that bike
before we do that let's look a little
bit sort of his descriptions of this he
talks about people holding grudges
neighbors throwing rocks
at their pottery people being liable to
go up and punch other people in the head
this is pretty descriptive right this is
this is the kind of common thing that we
see quite often people become angry they
become as it cause a querulous that
means they're complaining about other
people it is the whole gamut of really
being a jerk to other people and
thinking that it's the right thing for
you to do so that gets us back to this
question why do they behave that way so
Epictetus tells us that this is the
nature of every being to pursue the good
and flee from the evil okay so that is
part of not just human nature but also
animal nature the problem is is that
these people are mistaken about what
genuinely is good and evil and so
they're going to get themselves into
conflicts with other people because they
think for example that honor is a good
thing or the lack of honor is a bad
thing they you know think that whatever
it is that they desire they really ought
to have and then you know other people
are going to get in the way so Epictetus
tells us that we they consider the man
who robs one of you know the good and
invest them with the the other the evil
as an enemy and as an aggressor even if
they have some sort of relationship with
them even though he'd be a brother even
though he'd be a son even though he'd be
a father for nothing as closer kin to us
he says that our own good this is the
way that human beings are so it's very
important that we get our ideas right
about what is in fact genuinely good and
evil for ourselves so if we don't do
that he says that we become like like
animals any he talks about three
different kinds here I'm two of which he
he talks about in other places I'm quite
frequently the sheet and the the beasts
of prey he says
a man whose sense of self-respect has
grown down he is his useless a sheep
anything but a human being here's a man
who does not listen to reason he does
not understand when he is confuted he's
an ass a donkey you know beasts of
burden here's a man who's looking for
someone he can kick or bite when he
meets him so he's not even a sheep or an
ass but rather some wild bees and
epictetus in other places talks about
you know when we give in to our animal
instincts for anger we become like wild
beasts we become like beasts of prey
when we get into our desire for for
pleasure for taking it easy we become
like sheep I suppose you can say when we
sort of hearted ourselves and won't
listen to other people we become like
asses and when we do that we set
ourselves up for all sorts of trouble
and we make trouble for everybody else
around us so how are we not end up like
that he says well one thing we want to
do is realize that are good in our evil
lies in our faculty of choice now if we
do that we are not going to retaliate
against the people who behave this way
because we'll be able to see that the
reason why they're acting like that
isn't because they're our enemies or
because they you know really in the
heart of heart hate us it's because
they're mistaken about what's really
good and what's evil and they're not
paying attention to the things that they
they want to be like you know what the
relationships are how this is damaging
to themselves and to others so you know
he goes on and he says if we do this we
will be gentle we will be patient will
be generous will be affectionate with
other people we won't retaliate and
here's the real test or even want to
retaliate against the contentious when
when they do that why because we see
things in the proper way so you know
he's got some examples here he says
where that is there any is there any
room for contention when a man is in
such a state is he not he is not filled
with Wonder and anything that happens is
he does anything seem strange Tim does
he not expect worse and harsher
treatment from the wicked than actually
befalls them if we understand the way
human beings are when they're screwed up
we're not going to be surprised when
they treat us badly and probably we
won't make ourselves as vulnerable to
them as well but when they do act badly
we can say well it's not as bad as it
could be right I'm great at he says from
where or what teacher did we learn that
man is a tame animal that a manifest
mutual affection that injustice that
injustice in itself is a great injury to
the unjust man that's what these people
are not learning that's what they don't
know that's what we do know and so we're
called to behave in a better way and
that's the right way for us to behave
writing in the sense that it's good for
us to do that he goes on and he says my
neighbor is thrown stones you got made a
mistake when your neighbors thrown
stones you have you know but my crockery
is broken are you a piece of crockery
then where are you your Faculty of
choice which is it you have to make a
decision are you going to be like these
people and identify you're good with
something external to yourselves then
you're going to get upset then you're
going to be just like them you're going
to retaliate or are you going to see it
as lying and the one thing that you
truly have control over he has a couple
other examples he says what them do you
want me to be despised and then he says
well who are you worrying about being
despised by by met of understanding how
are men of understanding going to
despise the gentle and the
self-respecting person no but my man
without understand well who cares what
they think what difference is that you
neither you nor any other
craftsman cares about those who are not
skilled in their art the art is the art
of living we shouldn't he's saying care
about what these people think they're
thinking is deranged that's why they are
like wild beasts instead we should care
about what other people who have their
head screwed on right and who are in
fact focusing on the the good being and
their faculty of choice and unimproved
themselves we should be concerned about
what they think and about forming some
sort of fellowship with them so a
Matthias doesn't think that we can in
any way sort of cure the brutal and the
contentious unless they recognize you
know at least the glimmerings of their
position not being right and decide to
go for some help we can't compel another
person's moral purpose what we can do is
prepare for the fact that we are going
to run into people like this and not
allow ourselves especially if we have an
inclination towards that to fall into
the same trap that they are
unfortunately stuck with them